[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il sera le meilleur francis lalanne ce
soir on va c'est un petit qu'il fallait
on va cueillir tout de suite notre
premier candidat c'est vous qui allez
bien sûr voter notre premier candidat
c'est benjamin lalanne c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
rien ne nous survivra
as tu vraiment
tlj mondiale
à savoir
je
le
je sais pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un banal et ça ne peut pas aller
trop mariella non messieurs hashtag
benjamin l'alarmé tellement du
chroniqueur http lalanne bravo bravo
attention donc voulait confier le micro
oui si vous voulez je pleure parce
qu'alors on est comme dans les
supermarchés ici on n'a qu'à me
attention c'est parti de là on va là-bas
que vous vous voir ici c'est l'art c'est
là attention on va cueillir maintenant
le deuxième pour dylan c max lalanne
attention c'est parti hashtag copé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
a metz la mémoire
et je n'oublie rien
[Musique]
ces deux chansons c'est pas mal en fait
je vous explique la mafia c'est que le
réalisateur qui réalise les missions
aujourd'hui michel et michel eu mon
chéri sur cette caméra il ya les paroles
donc si si tu me suis
le centre va être comme as en tant que
citoyens nous allons voir mais sans
rigoler tu vois pas que leurs champs et
ont commencé quand horticole masse tu
vois pas qui sont encore nicolas mas non
mais sans rigoler c'est pas beau jim
vous notez vous en tout cas vous
m'angoisser m'angoisser vous avez vu
qu'à delphine ce soir au salut delphine
je crois que c'est le mec qui a le plus
de répartie et on salue delphine au
centre en quoi on s'entend très bien
avec delfino sans merci les sages
instagram pas fait gaffe faire son mec
derrière péter la gueule car morgane
sont hostiles au el féni kabala j'aime
bien ça lui morgan
[Musique]
alors lui il vient de rentrer dans
l'émission c'était des chauffeurs
livreurs à la base je vous jure que
c'est vrai si vraiment ça des chauffe et
livrent tous les matins et c'est pas une
vanne et depuis quelques temps lui mais
c'est pas le mec de tps ici mais je dois
livrer quand même c'est la première fois
qu'ils se déguise je suis pas sûr du
tout de ce que je pense ça va être très
très court c'est parti c'est raymond
lalanne
[Applaudissements]
tu brises
[Musique]
qui me tient
pas
comme leur
[Applaudissements]
séparera
même pas
plus grands
si tu veux
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
blu ray mais si tu écris ta mère tu vas
où la bohème et ouais c'est écrit fadila
et la famille addams revient à lui nous
a fait une entrée jack fr gens beaux
gosses de ouf
sans déconner merci venez vous votez
http lalanne pas mal avec mon pas ce que
vous en pensez chez vous j'ai trouvé sa
part l francis qu'est ce qu'on pense
pour l'instant bien je pense donc
j'essuie je pense donc je suis merci
j'ai un côté ton spectacle et sans réel
qu'on loue pas parce que vos balcons et
francis tu vas nous le ferons en
acapulco
oui oui attention au texas et rend les
wizzards qui excusez moi vous là ont
violé qu'on allait réagir à tout ce
qu'on va dire dans toutes les maisons
excuse moi je me taire elle est drôle
aujourd'hui elle est drôle c est ce que
vous savez pourquoi parce qu'elle kiffe
la tenue on a vu et que voilà donc elle
dit je suis dans la phase aller c'est
surtout quel mec qui va venir ou casser
la gueule tout à leur maintien
triaulère ça fait six ans qu'on dit qu à
me casser la gueule pour l'instant
j'attends toujours
donc je veux bien avoir votre avis c'est
un ami internationale et c'est qui c'est
mister bean vers l'histoire bling va me
taper un mot on va voir mais non elle a
l'air sûre d'elle il parle c'est une
grosse star sans lui paraît énorme
attention on va cueillir maintenant
c'est notre francis lalanne à nous c'est
une femme qui interprète francis lalanne
c'est isabelle lalanne c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
alors
burger avec moi
aïe aïe
alors qu'al honte à ses premiers témoins
de toute variante hôtel ok tu n'auras
merci merci ca a baissé lors d'un
conflit j'adore cette chanson tu vas y
vas tu l'écoutera chez tu écouteras
celle où aller jour où rennes avec moi
reste avec moi mon nom joe borg
[Rires]
allez on va accueillir le dernier
francis lalanne a c'est mon petit favori
s'appelle matt arcis merci pour nous
narrer vous je vous adore aussi oui mais
parce qu'il a il a un beau grain de voix
non raymond pour l'instant il numéro un
pour moi ça me dit tout de suite c'est
beaucoup mieux pour tout le monde et pas
tellement attention cette partie mathieu
lalanne on y vendent plus
[Applaudissements]
vous
livrera deux
[Musique]
m
je tuerai
je sais pas
mais non
les
dubé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour toi
les cherry on va voir tout de suite les
résultats quel meilleur francis lalanne
et vous irez le faire pendant le
facebook live dans la rue si si flash
mob tout le monde en francis lalanne
dans la rue on se donne rendez-vous
quelque part alors en arrive là j'ai pas
tout le temps global a tout de suite
mais au président avec plaisir organise
sa atteint moi je viens c'est matthieu
delormeau vôtre
[Applaudissements]